[音楽]
真珠の道
したあああ
クズ送る入っておりです信者でございますこちら
もうあのカーっても何もついてないから持ったダメなんですよそこ
水素が見せられるんだけどめっちゃ広いんですよ
十分すぎる夫婦はあるのかなと思います恋比率に
パウリ好きなあー
すげー日々で鼓動なさいって言うねぇ
[音楽]
ずっとこうやろしと部屋になる
根本もう一つも枚になりましたいや中
uh
[拍手]
の
nar はこれで男装コステクノがたちが受けないです
何度今心境
[音楽]
63戸ありますうっ
嘘ですねそうでそのないですねという意味でまた問題はないんですけど
ここであれだしているかどうかなと思っております
霧なもの入れないとってあのー
響くはもっと狭い部屋に行こうそっちの良いははいというわけでここが東京の新居で
ございます
田臥日ですが普通にちゃんとした引っ越しが増えぶりですごい楽しみだしあの東京の
物件に実はスキマ時間見てめっちゃくちゃ回りまくったんですよ
ドンが描いていいんだっけ普通に10個以上みたいなものすごい数のお家とな物件とか
親見てここにしようって決めましたねまあいろんな理由があるんですけどまだそので
あってる
oo 迷惑かかるのは一番ダメてそれで一番強かった桜って人が多い簡単です多いです
ぞや罵倒じゃん苦情来たら他のタイプのはさせ管理相談でしっかりと棒とかそこらへん
をしっかりしてるとこにさせていただきました後はねやっぱり翼だね静岡で撮ってた級
の動揺を取るとなると並大抵の大きさだったのは卒業で不利だと思ってるって
その部屋の大きさとかを簡単に御気にしますかコソコソしててもしかないんで堂々と
東京で盗賊君たら取ろうと思って
[音楽]
かけましたはいという感じですね動画どんどん出して口にねこの部屋の間取りとか他の
部屋とかも出てなんか2章特定とかなぁ
カレー dentec 思うんですけどなるべくやめてくださいとかだとそうで免停に
なりたくないんでと気がしますてみてくださ負けのセキュリティーとも1しかしても
大丈夫だと思うんですけど
ここが私はずっ
新しい拠点になりますいやーちょっとね東京車展示だからまだどういうテンションで
いればいいかはなんだよ
ものの運び込みも何持ってきてないんでちょっとずつ明るとかものは増えていくかなと
思っています今マジでゼロでなんでもない状態
はいという感じで東京での生活が始まりました
まあけどたしかで普通に3日間でしたらまた静岡へてるんですけどなんか東京て結局
その人が多いからさぁ今日客様ユーチューバーもいいからねコラボとかも住みやすそう
ですよちょっとづつでいいね東京でしか撮れない動画とか持っていけ
ますと言いつつも静岡もしっかり帰って地図をかでしか撮れないの鳥も陵王美味しいと
思えばいいという感じですね
久々22普通に1人っきりになって気がしますね
酒造家にいるときももう絶対誰がいるし絶対だけど行ったんですけども
ね久々に東京でお部屋を構えてなんかすごい初心にかえった気がします
一人で堂々とるっていうなぁ
ようになるでしょどうも私は鶴酒造一刻も早く東京女子生活に慣れようと思うので皆
さんも的
東京はじめシャツをられてください
[音楽]
blr